The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, so it looks
like we've got everybody here.
It's about 1:11.
Today in class, we are going
to end our project twos.
Yay.
We feeling good about this?
Kinda?
I'm feeling good about this.
And we're going to
start project three.
So we're going to start off with
our project two presentations.
Again, we're going
to go through here.
Each team has five minutes
to give their presentation.
Slides.
You can set up your
slides up here.
We've carved out
enough time for today
to be able to swap out
between computers and for us
to ask a couple of questions
after each presentation.
After all the
presentations are done,
we're going to take a break.
Instructors will kind
of talk to each other
about what we saw in
the presentations,
and we'll address some of
the feedback that we heard,
some of the things that we
saw in the presentations.
As a reminder,
presentations, we want
to hear about what went
right, what went wrong,
and also what would
you do differently?
Then we're going to
start project three.
And we're going to do
brainstorming in class.
Basically, the
first week of class
we're going to compress into
about 30 minutes of this class.
We're going to
brainstorm, we're going
to do our elevator pitches, and
then we're going to form teams.
So we're going to do that
really, really quick.
And it might require
rolling the die again.
It might require moving you
from project to project.
And that's going to be OK.
We'll talk about why we're
doing that when we go.
So I think that's
everything from me.
Any questions?
And if not, Sparkly
Redemption, come on down.
PRESENTER 1: So what went right?
The game got made.
It isn't broken or sad or dead.
Even though we had
to cut some things,
I feel like the general
idea of you are a player
and you pick up sparklies and
your sparklies change monster
behavior slash your
power-up slash whatever
got implemented pretty
well in a way that carried
across our original idea.
What went wrong?
I guess we had to
drop some things.
We had a person on our
team not get hit by a bus,
but they did basically
not have as much time
to work on the project
as much as we thought.
So we had to adapt to that.
On the other hand, I feel like
we adapted to that pretty well.
So not good, but still
good, I think, personally.
We were told to test
early and test often,
which I think we actually kind
of did-- maybe not as early
or as often as we could have.
But we still tested even
when we had something
that we felt wasn't
really testable
but was still touchable.
And I feel like that was
kind of interesting to do
because people kept
telling us, you
should totally be able to die.
And we were like,
yes, we do think
you should be able to die, but
we haven't implemented that.
And so on and so forth.
But on the other
hand, that meant
we still got lots and lots
of good feedback and things
to think about, like
stuff that we probably
wouldn't have thought to
have implemented but still
implemented because we
caught that early on.
So yes, test early and test
often, even if it's annoying,
is what I learned, and
I feel we all learned.
And that might be
all I can think of.
PROFESSOR: What would you
do differently next time?
PRESENTER 1: What would I
Meet up with people.
Well, not necessarily
physically,
because we scheduled
meetings but then we
decided maybe we don't
need to physically meet up
because it's a pain
getting people onto campus
if they don't live on campus,
which would have been fine.
But then there were still
times we were like, well,
we meant to meet up
but then we got iffy
about scheduling a time,
and everyone got confused.
And I feel like we managed
to work our way through it.
But it was still
more of a hassle
than it probably needed to be if
we just sat down and scheduled
out a chunk of time
and listed things
that we were going to get done.
So differently would
be better about meeting
with each other,
either physically
or through the interwebs.
PROFESSOR: Any
questions from anybody?
OK.
Which game engine
was that again?
PRESENTER 1: Sparkly Redemption.
It's the one-armed lady.
PROFESSOR: What game
engine did you use?
PRESENTER 1: Oh.
Phaser.
AUDIENCE: Anything to
say about the experience
of working with Phaser?
PRESENTER 1: So you do the
thing where you have a bug
and you think it's
Phaser related,
so you Google vague terms.
And I've worked with
Flixel and Unity,
so I know personally I'm used
to having long form posts pop up
that you then dig through.
But I feel like with Phaser
it was a bit of a mixed bag.
And sometimes you
got relevant posts.
Or sometimes you just went
to the Phaser examples
and kept digging through it
until you found something
vaguely relevant.
So it wasn't terrible,
but it was still
not quite what I was used to in
terms of figuring things out.
PRESENTER 2: So we're
Lost Underground.
One of the biggest things I
felt our team had a problem with
was communication.
Because at the very beginning,
we were really good.
We all got really
pumped for this project,
and we got together.
We had the paper prototype.
We edited it a bunch.
We quickly got that over
to a digital prototype.
And then it kind of stagnated.
We had the play testing, and
we learned a lot from that.
One of the most
interesting things
is we added the darkness
mechanic, where you can only
see a certain zone around you.
And some people felt
like you shouldn't
be able to see as much.
People felt you should be
able to see more or less.
Everyone had different opinions.
But we liked the way it worked.
But it didn't work the
way we wanted it to.
People weren't concerned
about walking around at all.
The whole point of the dark is
to be afraid of it, like oh,
is there a monster
over there, but there
could be something to
collect, and people
weren't feeling that.
And so we found out
from the play testing
we needed to change it.
And the best way to do
this was to shrink it
so you could see even less,
to zoom out the camera so you
feel really claustrophobic
and far away from everything.
And I think that
really helped us.
We also learned--
what was really
funny is we had
just a placeholder,
a little coffee cup,
instead of a coin, which
is what we originally went for.
But every play tester
was like, oh, coffee.
That's the coolest thing.
I love the idea of
collecting coffee.
And so one of the cool
things about play testing
is if you don't say
anything, they will give you
really useful information,
even though that's not
what you intended at
all, which was really
cool to experience firsthand.
And so we decided to stick
with the coffee mechanic,
and it ended up being a
little more silly than what
we originally planned for.
But like I said,
communication was really hard.
Planning out who was going to
do what with a digital prototype
was much more difficult
than with a paper prototype,
I personally feel.
Because code intermingles
in a way that paper doesn't.
And so it becomes
really difficult
when people are pushing
things and pulling things
and then things break.
And so that was really hard.
A way to change
this, I feel like,
would be to just make
sure everyone replies
to their emails, and make
sure people are talking
and everyone knows
what's going on.
And I don't know the
best way to do this.
Maybe an IRC chat,
where they constantly
have that chat channel
there and people
can look at it
when they want to.
Because emails kind of get lost.
And text messages people
forget to reply to.
So something like that,
where it's constantly there
and you can go look
at it and hopefully
reply to it in a timely manner.
Or maybe just have--
one of the things
I did in my other classes
is the very beginning,
everyone had to write
up a contract of when
you'd be working on things,
when you reply to things.
And so we had to
sign and say, I will
reply to any emails about
this at 9:00 PM every day.
And so you can expect a
reply by my by 10:00 PM.
And so because we
had this contract,
we knew-- if I send an email
to this person before 9:00 PM,
I will get a reply
an hour later, which
was really useful when
people were a little hectic
and they had other things to do.
At least I knew I would
get that email back.
So any questions?
PROFESSOR: So same
question as before.
What game engine did you use?
PRESENTER 2: So we used Phaser.
And any coding
questions, I'm going
to direct to another team member
who was more heavily invested
in it than I was.
PROFESSOR: Anybody want
to speak up about coding?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
curious about Phaser.
PRESENTER 3: I thought Phaser
was an interesting engine
to use.
I think in terms of the
organization of the code,
you have to do a lot of
thinking beforehand if you
want to make it work well.
I guess it could be a
little finicky when you just
start building, because we
thought, OK, well, we'll
add code, and then we'll
sort of architect it
based on what we see happening.
But then we came to realize
that our code wasn't
going to be as separable
as we thought it might be.
I also ran into a couple of
bugs that were in Phaser itself
that I had to sort
of dance around.
So I would say watch
out for the fact
that there are still
some bugs in it.
PRESENTER 4: Yeah,
just callback nastiness
and having to think about
something will happen now-ish.
Time isn't really now-now.
It's like, now kind of
now, then kind of then,
floating point numbers
that are somehow always
floats and nothing
is ever actually
equal to anything else.
PROFESSOR: Is any
of that documented?
PRESENTER 4: This
is just found out.
That's JavaScript.
But I thought we could get away
from JavaScript by wrapping
that all in an engine, but no.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
PRESENTER 5: Hello.
We were Plunder Winds.
So starting off with the good.
I think our team was actually
pretty well organized,
and our roles were well-defined.
So from the very beginning,
we set up task lists and lines
of communication.
We set up a mailing
list and then
assigned everybody
specific roles.
And then from that, we
were able to-- none of us
duplicated work.
And we set up a good
architecture early on.
And so we used Phaser.
And unfortunately, there's
this one part of Phaser
that's not really
well documented
in any of the examples and
tutorials which is the state
machine that Phaser has.
Surprise, there's a
state machine in Phaser.
And then once we discovered
that-- we discovered
that early on and used it.
And so that allowed us to
really architect our code well
and separate out modules.
And we also used a JavaScript
module thing, which basically
made it so that all of our
coding efforts were really--
were really efficient, I think.
And as for the bad,
five out of six,
or basically our
entire team, came down
with the flu the first week,
or over the first weekend.
And that really
impacted our schedule.
So originally we had wanted
to get a playable prototype
by the first weekend so we
could get people touching it
and start getting feedback.
But the plans best
laid, it doesn't
help if everyone gets sick.
So we had a large
schedule impact.
And the way we had to deal
with that was, like, there's
one guy who was able to code
throughout the entire first
week.
And then the rest of us
were playing catch up.
And so we didn't get
anything playable
until the in-class
workshop on Wednesday.
And I think that really
hurt us because we weren't
able to get a lot of
important feedback
until very late in the process.
And so there were some
features that we kind of added.
And we were like, this may
address player concerns.
But we just didn't get
enough feedback or data
to figure out whether or not
those concerns were actually
really addressed.
PROFESSOR: And anything
you'd do differently?
PRESENTER 5: I think
we would not get sick.
But also, we set up Asana
and everything on Monday.
But then we learned,
like, oh, we
have to do a sprint task
list and a product backlog
on Wednesday.
So I think there was
a bit of a weird issue
there, where we already had
one task management system,
and then we introduced
another one.
And then we introduced scrum
boards and we were like, well,
which one do we use?
And then we just didn't
end up using any of them.
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
So my question, I think,
is you had the flu.
A bunch of people were out.
You didn't cut features.
You tried to just catch up.
Did you think about
cutting features?
Do you feel like you ended
up cutting anything at all?
PRESENTER 5: So I think our core
game was actually, like-- it
was pretty simple to implement.
And I just want to give
a shout-out to our team.
You guys pulled
off an awesome job
and implemented
everything by Wednesday.
And so we did actually
manage to get a feature
complete game by Wednesday.
And then we started adding
tweaks, like interface tweaks
and maybe a visual cue here
and there throughout the rest
of the week.
But in terms of
cutting features,
we didn't really have any
complex time-intensive features
that we would have benefited
from cutting, I don't think.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
PRESENTER 6: So our project
was Beaver Evolution.
And so I guess I'll first go
through three of the bigger
design challenges
we came up with
or that we encountered
during these two weeks.
And our [? system ?]
was working with Phaser,
which is kind of design, kind
of the project challenge.
And so one thing
we ran into is we
didn't realize there was
this thing called stages,
and I think you guys
just mentioned that.
But since everything is
turn-based, and in each turn
you can make a choice
between building, populating,
and evolving, and then
disaster might strike.
So there was different
things that happen.
So we thought it
could be very modular
and we could use stages.
But then we learned that
stages really start and stop
every time you switch stages.
So it doesn't take
the info about what
happened in a previous
stage, which was
really important to our game.
So then we ended up having
to switch everything over
to Phaser groups, so we could
hide groups and show groups.
So that was one of
our first challenges,
just kind of figuring
out how Phaser worked
and what would be
best for our code.
It turned out our
code was very modular
because there were so
many different elements
to each turn.
So it was very easy
to split up the work.
And that was helpful.
Overall, we really liked Phaser.
Our second challenge
is balancing the game,
so making it not too easy to
win and not too hard to win.
And we kind of changed that by
changing some of the winning
conditions and then also
adding a few mechanics here
and there to make
the game harder.
Because often it
was just too easy.
So for example, you
could just keep evolving.
Or you could keep
populating your beavers.
And then once you reached the
number of beavers you needed,
you'd win.
But we kind of changed
that by implementing
a rule where you can't
populate every turn because you
have to [INAUDIBLE].
So I guess the slide
is not really working.
PRESENTER 7: Yeah.
So I'm not sure why the
screen won't show our slides,
but we can keep
talking about the game.
So Rachel talked a
lot about the design
challenges we ran
into for the game.
And so I'll talk about some
of the project challenges
that we ran into.
I was assigned the role
of the product manager.
So you remember the product
manager in the scrum roles
is the person who's supposed to
sort of lead where the game is
going and make sure that all
the design implementations are
the way that they're
supposed to be and handle
any changes that we need
to make to the code.
So unfortunately,
we didn't explicitly
assign a scrum master.
So by taking on the role of
being the product manager,
I also assumed some of the
roles of the scrum master.
And I know that this
was stated to us
in the lecture about scrum,
how we should definitely not
do that.
And we now see why.
I unfortunately had to run
some of the meeting-- I
unfortunately had to focus
on running the meeting
as well as on making
sure that the design was
going in the direction
it was supposed to go.
So I definitely lost
some efficiency there.
And we started off
very efficient.
We were able to assign tasks,
and our product backlog,
our sprint task lists,
were all very laid out.
We had an early
meeting to make sure
that everything was going well.
But then by the end, I just sort
of started running out of time.
We were unable to schedule a
meeting after the play testing
session due to everybody's
schedules being very tight.
And so some of the
changes that we
wanted to implement after
the feedback from the testing
session we were
unable to implement.
But we were still able to
get a good game together.
Our organization just sort of
fell apart towards the end.
So those were probably
some of the biggest design
problems we ran into.
I would definitely next
time, for our next project,
make sure that there's
a clear product
manager and a clear scrum
master so that those two
roles can be done very
efficiently and not overlap.
PRESENTER 6: Yeah.
And I'll just add
on, so our testing
we really realized that
user experience could
be improved between having all
the players know all the game
mechanics and rules
coming into the game.
So yeah, in addition to
not being able to meet up,
not being able to
play all the features,
we really just focused on
improving game experience
by adding audio and by
adding smaller things.
But I think earlier
in the game, we
should have thought more
about user experience
and making sure that
was a good flow.
PROFESSOR: Are
there any questions?
I think you covered everything.
Thank you.
PRESENTER 8: All right.
We're Comcastic.
So as you'll recall,
our game involves
placing service centers
on a map and trying
to cover all of the houses.
So what went wrong-- setting
up Phaser took a long time.
It was really hard for us to
actually start writing code.
We were using TypeScript,
which was important,
I think, for us, especially
as a documentation.
But it took some time to
get a good set-up where
you had a posted Phaser
where everybody could develop
and you had
TypeScript integrated.
And it would be nice if--
future projects, I think,
will be set up for that.
But for the first
project, that was hard.
Meetings-- it was really
hard to schedule meetings.
We had seven people
when we started,
and we went down to six.
And even at six, it was still
hard to schedule meetings,
mostly because of PSETs.
I had one PSET, but everybody
else had a lot of PSETs,
and it was a lot of
conflicting times.
What went right-- so
Phaser itself, I think,
really helped us develop fast.
Once we got the hang of Phaser,
it was a lot easier to develop.
It was pretty consistent.
The code is pretty good.
It was not hard to debug by just
looking at Phaser code for us.
Also, I think we got the
synchronous communication down,
because we really didn't
meet that often, especially
as a whole group.
So we were using
Trello, and it was
really nice to just
sort of bounce an idea
off Trello, just put
in [INAUDIBLE] feature,
and then we would sort
of discuss it via Trello.
I think that that's something
that we want to keep doing.
Also balance-- I think
our balance is actually
pretty good.
It was sort of a coincidence
that our pieces--
so the components of our
balance are basically
how the map looks,
where the houses are,
and then also the service
centers you can place are.
And you can imagine it'd be kind
of difficult to make these two
match up, but I think our
first random attempts ended up
working pretty well.
What we would do differently--
we would definitely
stick to one communication tool
and stick to something simple.
I think Trello was fine,
[? but even ?] GitHub issues
would be good, and they would
integrate with the code.
Definitely we want to keep
scheduling partial meetings
with some of the group,
just the programmers, just
a handful of people, whoever
can make it to one meeting.
I think with students that ends
up being the best thing to do.
And getting a [INAUDIBLE]
viable product out early on-- I
think we underestimated how
important that was, even just
getting a Phaser set up where
you have an empty game running
quickly.
Even that, if you get that done
in two hours versus two days,
it makes a huge difference.
PROFESSOR: Any
questions from anybody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 8: Yes,
face-to-face meetings.
Even Google Hangouts
actually weren't
easy to get everybody
at one time.
PROFESSOR: All right, thank you.
PRESENTER 9: Hi.
We're Modudice.
That is our game.
For those of you that
played it, it's sort of
like a number-puzzle type game.
You move around a dice.
You add numbers,
a module of seven.
And you want to make as many
sevens on the board as you can,
and you get points.
And so what went well for
us is our design meetings
went quite well.
We had two or
three of these that
were basically dedicated
to figuring out,
how do we do this better?
And how do we answer some
of the questions that
came up during testing?
And I feel like those
went really well.
We were able to get
good discussion.
We actually came up with,
like, solid answers.
And we were convinced, like, OK.
This may not be
the best way to go,
but it's definitely comparably
good to anything else.
So we're going to
just stick with this.
And we were able to make task
lists as a result of that.
So we decide on something
and then say, OK,
what do we need to do
to actually do this?
And I think that went
across fairly well.
And we did a lot of good
testing, especially the testing
we did in class.
And on top of that,
like, all of us
just tested the game
with our friends,
since it's, like, fairly
easy to play and sort of fun.
So yeah, the testing
was really useful.
And we actually did change
a lot as a cause of it.
PRESENTER 10: I'd like
to add to the task list
that I think we also did
a very good job in terms
of prioritizing what
tasks were important.
I'd like to say that we cut
two features-- the dice rolling
animation and sound.
And I think those were
really good feature cuts
because they weren't
central to our game-play
as a very fast-paced
browser game.
And cutting them actually
saved us a lot of work
and let us have the time
to spend on other features
and stuff.
PRESENTER 9: And Phaser
was good in the sense
that it was something
that went well,
because it was
easy to start with
and it was fairly easy to use.
Like, once you knew what you
needed to do with Phaser,
it was pretty simple
to get it going.
But it was also a bad
thing because it's Java.
At least we did
it in JavaScript.
So JavaScript is
hard to work with,
hard to fix bugs and stuff.
And I could see-- like,
Phaser was fine because it
was a fairly small project.
I could see Phaser being
absolutely horrible
for large projects.
Like, I would never
want to use it ever.
PRESENTER 11: I actually
thought that it actually
did not have a lot
of good documentation
when we were trying things.
I thought the community was
not the best for Phaser.
PRESENTER 9: And so Git,
I think, is awesome.
But a lot of people
weren't familiar with Git.
And so the branching
was confusing.
And that became an issue.
So if you're going to use a
[? version control ?] like Git,
make sure everyone
understands it.
That's something we learned.
And getting tasks
done separately--
we thought that would be
most efficient, since we're
everywhere across campus, it's
hard to meet up and stuff.
But I think it's actually
better to just at least start
working together.
When you have a set of tasks,
begin the work together,
do as much as you can,
and make sure everyone's
clear on how to do
what they need to do
and what exactly they need
to do so that everyone feels
like they are actually
contributing and working
together on this.
PRESENTER 12: I want to add
one more point on Phaser,
in the sense that-- I feel like
Phaser-- we're trash-talking it
right now, but I think Phaser
is good for a one-person project
because it's very easy to
manage the stuff on your own.
But with larger
groups, I just don't
like reading through
JavaScript spaghetti code.
So maybe we needed to find
a better way to organize
our code with more people.
But I just didn't like-- like,
I edited a piece of code,
someone else edited it,
and I was like, wow,
it's totally different from
what I expected it to be.
PRESENTER 9: And
so yeah, next time
it would definitely help
to have scrum meeting
and work physically together,
so basically just spend
more time together as opposed
to messaging on email and stuff.
Make sure everyone
understands the source control
and the engine.
And like, have more people
really think about-- like,
have everyone on the team really
think about design decisions.
And then communicate,
communicate.
More communication
definitely would hurt.
PRESENTER 10: I would
like to add to that
in terms of the communication.
Because as a new
member of a team who
joined the Modudice, not
the original Modudice team,
we didn't actually host
an information session
about what were the critical
things about the game,
that we made it
the way we made it.
So the new members, such
as me, had difficulty
to put in variable input, at
least for the starting duration
of the project, and then
we picked up later on.
But if we had an information
session, something like that,
it would be very helpful.
PROFESSOR: Any
questions from anybody?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE].
When you said that your
design meetings-- this was
all the way on your first
slide, were those online?
Or were those in person?
PRESENTER 9: It was in person.
But those were mostly
focused, like-- so we
had a lot of questions of how
to represent the dice in 2D
and stuff like that.
So the design
meetings were mostly
focused on big
questions like that.
PRESENTER 11: In
addition, I think
we had [INAUDIBLE] meetings.
And I thought that we should
just have multiple smaller
ones, [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 9: It ended up
going, like, two hours.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
PRESENTER 13: So what was bad?
We're going to start
with the bad things.
The first decision
we made as a team
was using Unity 2D, because
that was just the majority vote.
Most people had worked with
Unity for the project before.
But it ended up having
too many complications.
And it was actually a good
thing that we switched
to Phaser very early on.
Like, two days into the
project we switched to Phaser.
So Unity [INAUDIBLE].
Second thing, we weren't
paying too much attention
to the assignments.
Everyone was focusing
on the game development
and making the game look good.
And we weren't updating
the product backlog,
and a change log [INAUDIBLE].
So we had to go back
and remember what
we worked on in the past week.
And it was very
asynchronized with that.
Another thing is we put off a
lot of the work until the day
before they were due.
Like, the last project
we had a lot of things
that could have been
done during the week,
but the night before,
we always have
hundreds of emails to sending
the emails around, trying
to get everything
to actually work.
And that was a thing that
cut off on our productivity.
Another thing is that we didn't
really have a lot of meetings.
We only had two meetings
throughout the entire project,
which had a downside that we
weren't very synchronized.
Even in some of those meetings,
some of us couldn't make it.
So we had to update whoever
wasn't there with what
happened in the meetings
and things like that.
And we definitely could
have used more meetings
to keep our work synchronized.
The last part is CoffeeScript.
CoffeeScript was a
good and a bad thing.
I think it was a good
decision overall,
but it definitely
had bad parts to it,
which is that we had
to sort of-- there's
a hack-ish with Phaser that
had to compile CoffeeScript
to JavaScript, which caused
some problems with the
[? gulping, ?] where it
would sometimes not work.
And we had to run it twice.
It generated JS files
which we had to not
commit into the source
control because they
were changed when the
CoffeeScript files would
change.
And so there was some
problems with it.
But once we had
it up and running,
it was so easy to write code
and just iterate on the code.
It was also easy to read
other people's code,
because it simplified
100 lines of JavaScript
into two lines of CoffeeScript.
I'm exaggerating.
And then finally, also, it
optimized the JS when compiled,
so it would run faster.
PRESENTER 14: So talking about
now some things that went well
in addition to
finding CoffeeScript,
we had really great group
direction from the get-go.
Even though we didn't
have a lot of meetings,
I think one way we
still managed to make
that work was we divided bigger
tasks into the sub-categories
really quickly.
And we also set
up a Google folder
in which we kept everything.
We didn't end up using
Trello or anything like that
because we really found that a
Google folder with everything
in it was the simplest for
us-- that along with just
one chain email where we
sent everything really
kept everything focused and
everybody in communication,
in the loop, as
best as possible.
So source control, we
used Git and GitHub.
And we actually had a
great experience with that.
I'm sorry some people didn't.
Nothing ever broke,
and we barely
had to merge because
I don't think
we did very much branching,
which is the way I think
we avoided any problems there.
So iteration-- we
iterated our game a lot.
We changed a lot of
things, because we'd
play it and be like,
well, people keep dying,
so how can we make that better?
Another example is
with our sprites,
as you can see up there--
so the initial designs
and then what we
changed them to.
We actually had a
problem where somebody
looked at our first
alien design and said,
that looks like a piece
of the female anatomy.
That is distracting.
You need to change it.
And we said, OK, you might
have a valid point there.
Even if we don't think
so, maybe it does.
Let's change it.
So we iterated a lot.
And then focus testing--
we really actually
implemented-- talking
about iteration,
in our focus testing,
the two things we
found were that new players
were dying really fast.
It took them, like,
five times before they
realized how to play the game.
And then, in addition to
that, after five minutes,
they were getting bored.
So we actually
took that to heart,
and we changed one of the main
premises of our game, which
was this reloading
thing, that it
would take a couple of seconds
before you could shoot again.
And instead, we added
a short term goal
of actually picking up ammo.
So you can see-- it's
kind of hard to see.
But the ammo-- the big
thing is just the animation.
But if you can see on the
screen, there's a player,
there's the ammo,
and there's a bug.
And basically we changed that
whole way the player actually
shot to make the game a little
more difficult over time
but also starting easier,
by having everybody smaller
and then the bugs get bigger.
So a lot of changes
and iteration
even based on our focus testing.
What we would change--
we'd start earlier.
I know we talked
about a lot of changes
we made were the night
before things were due.
Pretty much all of our
documents changed the night
before they were due.
And it's kind of
frustrating, you
know, having to stay up really
late the night before it's due
when you've had the
whole week to do it.
So just start earlier.
I mean, we started pretty early,
but finish earlier, definitely.
Hands off for the last
12 hours, kind of thing.
And then we also talked
about this-- being
focused on what's actually due.
So one thing that was good
about having a lot of focus
on our game was that we had a
viable product really early.
But a lot of our other documents
kind of fell by the wayside,
and they kind of came
up to one or two people
to just fix them all the
night before they were due.
So definitely focus on those
things and more accountability
with that.
And in conclusion, even though
we had some frustrations,
it went pretty well.
Our game ended up pretty
clean and creep and fun.
So we really like it.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Questions?
AUDIENCE: How did you
stumble upon CoffeeScript?
What was the decision when you
were trying to [INAUDIBLE]?
PRESENTER 13: Jen, you
want to take this one?
AUDIENCE: If you could
come down [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 15: I used
CoffeeScript a lot
before I was really
familiar with the
build systems and stuff.
So I figured it'd be
best to kind of set
up a build pipeline that
optimizes the [? alpha ?]
JavaScript to make the game
run faster because [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 13: And CoffeeScript
also has a lot of shortcuts.
It's like Python.
It's like using
Python to write Java.
It's so good.
Like that.
PRESENTER 14: Any
other questions?
PROFESSOR: Thanks.
OK, feedback.
And instructors, please
feel free to jump in
if I'm missing anything.
Oh, and I forgot to
copy all my notes.
All right.
So yeah, I was wrong.
Ha, you caught me.
Slides were intended to be
required for this project,
but they were not.
So you're not going to
get penalized for that.
The issue for that
is slides and visuals
are recommended to help your
presentations stay on topic.
Basically, you had
some issues sometimes
with keeping track of changes.
We had some issues with
keeping track of our changes
to our documents.
So QA is important in
everything that we do in life.
But for project three,
slides and visuals
are recommended to help your
presentations stay on topic.
And what we saw
presentation-wise,
slide-wise, was perfect
for these five minute
presentations.
Quick, dirty, gets
the point across,
gets the bullets across.
Visuals, like images or
something, if you need it.
For project four, that's
a 20-minute presentation.
Visuals are more
important there.
And we'll talk about those
presentation requirements
later when we
start project four.
So discussion on
meetings, things
you should do in
project three-- address
how you're going to meet in
your initial design meeting.
The most important
thing you have,
before you even start
designing your game,
is to talk about who can meet
when, what is your schedule.
You all have syllabuses
from your other classes.
When are your PSETs due,
when are your recitations,
all that stuff.
Put it in your high-level
design document.
It's actually one
thing that we use often
in that one section where
we talk about team roles,
is team meeting times.
And I think I heard
this team mention that,
that you've used in
previous classes.
That's a very good tip.
Use that.
If others can't make
it to your meetings,
is there a way you
can take video?
Is there a way you
can archive what
happened in the meeting for
those people who couldn't come?
Here's something that I've
seen some local companies do--
drop in IRC.
Basically, even something as
simple as keeping Skype open.
Even better-- actually, my
notes weren't put in there.
Even better, an
IRC solution that
has some kind of
archival process
in, so all the previous
chat can be saved.
I know there are some solutions
out there that actually
hook this into your GitHub or
Bitbucket or what you're using.
Those solutions are out there.
Try one of them.
But again, even something
as simple as having
Skype open and
online, you can always
tell if one of your
team members is online.
You can throw a
text and say, hey,
can I get your feedback on this?
Can you take a
look at this code?
For your daily scrum, 15
minute Hangouts probably
is-- all you need is
15 minutes for doing
that kind of daily scrum
meeting, so trying that out.
Problems we saw with backfilling
your product management.
Integrate your project
management from the beginning.
We know that this was a
problem for this project
because we introduced it
to you midway through.
That's OK.
You actually did--
we mentioned this,
you did some pretty good
use of product management.
The goal for any
project management
tool that we're
teaching in this class
is that it should be helpful.
It shouldn't be a hindrance.
That said, we'd like you to
get some practice with it
first before you
start throwing it out.
So for project three, please
use the project management tools
that we described as we've
described them to you.
In particular, product
backlogs, sprint task lists,
and the design change log,
and the vision statements,
those high level
design documents.
Scrum boards, mostly optional,
but we found them useful.
They might not be useful for
how your team is distributed.
It's up to you to
figure that out.
For project four, we'll
give you the ability
to create the system
that works for your team,
so long as you give us what
information we're asking for.
So you know you need
this information.
You know you need a way
to manage your tasks.
to manage your features
and to prioritize your
features to estimate.
But how you actually do that
and how you actually save it,
that can be up to
you for project four.
We will want to see it actually
cause some improvements.
And if it doesn't
cause improvements,
let us know why and what kind
of problems you found with that.
And again, the
design change log.
This is a design diary.
It's even better.
It's your meeting minutes.
You should be able to fill
it out in five minutes.
Along with your task
list and backlog,
it kind of shows the
history of the project.
Take the time just to
spend those five minutes
at the end of each meeting
to just throw something
quick down so you know what
has changed in the past.
Phillip, you want to
chime in on this one?
Modular code doesn't mean your
tasks are actually separate.
PHILLIP: Yeah.
This is just
something that I got
a sense of from watching
everyone's presentations today.
A lot of folks, even the folks
who mentioned that the code was
well separated and people
could code independently,
it doesn't mean that
there are no benefits
to actually still working side
by side, even if you're working
on different parts of the code.
And some teams mentioned that.
So actually, again, being
on Google Hangout or Skype
or IRC or whatever, if you're
working in your own rooms,
or even better, a lot
of people mentioned
scheduling those face-to-face
meetings-- it's OK for you
to have a face-to-face
meeting, even
if you're not
planning on working
on the same batch of code.
And you can actually still save
a lot of communication time--
if nothing else, just to tell
people what you're doing.
So maybe it's not
speeding you up,
but it might speed
everybody else up,
and suddenly it helps
the communication.
PROFESSOR: Form strike teams.
You've got six people, maybe
seven people, and eight people
on project four.
Not everyone needs
to be touching code.
There are other tasks
that need to get done.
You can form up
into smaller teams.
One team might just be working
on some kind of-- again,
if it's modular, it's going
to have some dependencies.
But if you can
modularize it out, great.
But even better, especially
with project four,
when you have longer time, one
team doing paper modification,
doing UI elements, running
focus tests, while another team
is writing code.
Think about how you
can better utilize
all the personal resources
and all the man hours
you have without requiring
all these clashes
with so many people
touching the code.
It's that too many cooks in
the kitchen kind of thing--
not everybody needs to be doing
that, need to be touching that.
Here's another thing we noticed.
A lot of what you asked for
was basically more time-- just
various different ways of saying
you wished you had more time,
you wished you had
started earlier,
you wish you had iterated
earlier, the flu hit.
A lot of what you're
describing there
are things you're not going
to have any control over ever.
You never have control
over that stuff.
What you need to do is
focus on those things
that you can control.
So if you have illnesses, if you
have major technical problems,
the game is whatever
you decide the game is.
You've actually got some freedom
in this class in that you've
told us what the game is, and
we're actually even telling you
in the last week, again, tell
us, what was this game actually
supposed to be, so that
when things change midway
through the project,
be flexible.
Change what you're
delivering to us.
Make it so that whatever
you're delivering to us
runs, works, is playable.
This isn't a design class.
We're trying to teach
you some design skills.
But it's not focused on design.
So if the final game
isn't fun, it's sad,
but it's OK, so long as it runs,
so long as it's playable, so
long as it fits all the
requirements that we're asking
of you from the beginning.
I know it's weird.
This is the only
class we do this in.
Trust me.
All right.
So that's it.
Any other questions
about project two?
I think you all did
really, really well.
Really happy to see how
the presentations went out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any way
we can see what everyone did?
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Is there any way
we can see what everyone did?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
So one thing I highly
suggest, somebody on your team
email the video
game mailing list.
Video games, yeah.
I did the plurals wrong.
I never do that
right with mailing
lists. videogames@mit.edu--
email out a link to your game
to your classmates if you want
people to play it and give you
feedback on it.
At the end of every
project do that.
Actually, use that mailing
list as a resource for you
to talk to each
other across teams.
Hey, here's our game.
We need a little bit
of feedback on this.
My team is all sick.
Can somebody please play this
and tell me what's wrong?
Can you play this on
a different browser
and tell me if it's broken?
Take advantage of
that mailing list.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So
[INAUDIBLE] postmortem,
will we get more feedback on
project one and project two,
what the group grade was?
PROFESSOR: So there
are no group grades.
So what you're getting
is-- your grades, if you
look at the grading rubric, 20%
of your grade is individual.
The other 80% percent
is your group.
So the grade that
you get is basically
adjusted based on the
quality of the write-up.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And on project two, will we
get more feedback on everything
we've done, so we can better
plan for project four?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So for project two, you're going
to get feedback on your design
change log again.
You're going to get feedback
on your task list and product
backlog.
We just gave you feedback
on the presentations
and on those skills.
You're going to do that
again for project three.
You get your feedback on
the individual write-up.
Is there anything
I'm missing there?
And then game
functionality-- we're
going to give you
more feedback on game
functionality, because last
time we did that in class.
This time we're actually
going to play your digitally
released games.
We'll give you some
design feedback
there for product three.
PHILLIP: Yeah.
Because we could just show
the actual numerical grading
proclamations that
we do, but that's
meaningless without actually
explaining what it is.
So what we'll try to do is focus
more on actual text feedback
on what we thought were the
strengths or the weaknesses
of whatever you've given us.
PROFESSOR: That answer?
Cool.
Any other questions on grading?
All right, give
yourselves a round
of applause for
finalizing project two.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me double check to make
sure I didn't miss a break.
No, we just took a break.
Ha, ha.
All right.
So project three, you're going
to practice project management,
meaning you're going to use
those tools that we talked
to you about in the middle of
project two from the get-go,
with a slightly larger team.
Some of your teams were
five people this time,
minimum is going to be six.
We're going to make sure we
leave class today with at least
six people on each team.
And again, that's just
to get used to it.
Project eight, your minimum
is going to be eight people.
So with a larger
team, you're going
to focus on design iteration
to maximize usability
using user feedback through
independent user testing.
So the keywords there--
users, feedback, usability.
Those are things
we're going to be
looking at when we're
grading the functionality
of your games.
So for project management,
we mean create and use
a product backlog and
a sprint task list.
There's few turn-ins for that.
For design iteration,
you're going
to conduct focus testing and
user testing on your own.
And I'll touch on this
again, but basically you're
going to turn in two focus
test reports, one of which
can happen in class
on a scheduled day.
The other one must
happen outside of class
with a group of people
who are not in class.
So get people to test your game
and report back to us on that.
And again, maximize usability.
All the iteration that we
see you do on your games,
you should be iterating on that
user interface or that user
experience.
So we are going to ask
you to make a little bit
more complex game than before.
But really what we're
trying to get you to do
is make a complex game that
has a possibly problematic user
interface.
Give us an interface
that's good.
Give us a user experience that
matches the user experience
that you want to strive for
when you're designing the game.
PHILLIP: Just a quick thing.
We do have a couple
of lectures coming up
on designing for that.
But as Greg mentioned
earlier, this is not actually
the design class.
There is actually a different
design class that some of you
have taken and are going to be
distributed among the teams.
Or you might have taken, say,
Rob Miller's user interface
class, which also has a lot of
those same sort of concepts.
If you've taken any
of those classes,
you should be identifying
yourself to your teams,
because you probably
have actually
practiced designing
for usability
a lot more than a lot of the
other people in your group.
And that's what we're
going to be looking for.
But most importantly,
the testing
that we've been
talking about, we
are expecting you to
be able to do that.
And that anyone of
you have already
got the basic foundation of.
PROFESSOR: So our design
constraint-- we're leveling up
from planning for randomness.
We want to see trade-offs
in decision making.
So every decision
made by the player
must have a positive
and negative outcome
in their play state.
So first off, what
does that mean to you?
What do you think that means?
Jenny?
AUDIENCE: Good
things and bad things
happen when you take steps.
So you have to decide whether
the good things outweigh
the bad things at your
current point in time?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Basically it--
opportunity costs.
Risk management, future
risks, unknown risks.
There should be some
unknowns and knowns there.
So while the players
should know that there's
going to be some positive
and some negative,
they might not know the values
of those positive and negative
outcomes.
So there's some kind
of uncertainty going on
in the game there.
And then some of
the side effects--
sometimes when you
make a decision,
there's going to be an immediate
change in player state.
Sometimes it's going
to be a long term.
It's going to chain or combo
up from previous decisions,
causing problems
in later things.
So easy way to think
about this, again,
is of course strategy games.
But you're also welcome
to apply this to any genre
that you might
like to experiment
with in this project.
So here's some suggested goals.
Think of project--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do we still
have to use planning
for randomness in this game?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So there should be some amount
of randomness in this game.
So it's building onto it.
So there should be some
kind of uncertainty.
It's not the focus
of it anymore.
So project two and
project one were focusing
on just that randomness.
Project three should have some
of the randomness in there.
But really, what we want you
to focus on is trade-offs.
So that's a tool
in your toolbox.
Try it out.
If it doesn't work, if there's
a reason it doesn't work,
then don't use it.
But there should be
some uncertainty there.
And again, all this is
building up to project four.
So things you should try
out in project three--
work with new people.
The method we're going to
have to put you in teams
is going to try to do that.
So you'll be working
in different teams
with different people.
These are basically
auditions for project four.
Use a new game engine.
Did everybody use Phaser?
Yeah.
You're not using Phaser
for project three.
So we're going to basically
want you to go back to that game
engine tutorial, think
about the other game engines
you have available.
We had one team to use Unity,
and they had some issues
why they wouldn't use Unity.
And actually, those
issues will probably
apply for project three as well.
Maybe you don't
want to use Unity.
Maybe it's too scary.
Maybe it's a challenge.
Figure it out.
And the last one-- I
posted this to Stellar.
It's a light read.
Games For a New
Climate is basically
our handbook for project four.
Our client presented us
with this information.
This is basically
how games are used
for game based learning,
for climate change,
for talking about planning for
future risks, the complexity
of future risks.
Take a flip through the book.
Read it now.
Start it now.
Have it read by project four.
Again, we don't have
required reading here,
but you'll have a
better game, you'll
have a better
product if you take
a look at this and maybe even
do a little bit of research
on your own, which
is actually going
to be part of project four.
We'll talk about that later.
But if you want to make a
game that does this, you can.
If you want to make a
game for project three
that is a game to help a
policymaker understand the need
to spend money,
time, or resources
on disaster preparedness as
a result of climate change,
feel free.
Part of that trade-off
design challenge
is actually inside
of that statement.
The uncertainty is
inside of that statement.
Project three
actually would turn
into a possible
springboard and a way
to recruit people
for project four.
But again, you're
not necessarily
going to have the same group.
So it's up to you to
figure out if that's
going to be useful for
you on this team or not.
All right.
And then the hard
requirements-- please
read this handout on Stellar.
I'll actually read the handout
on Stellar too this time.
Sorry about that.
Maximum play length,
again, is five minutes.
Again, single player game.
User interface tested for
legibility and usability.
It must use and play
audio for the player.
And then, like
previously, players
can pick up and start
playing the game
with no external instructions.
So if there are instructions,
which there can be,
it must be inside of the
game or at least inside
of the frame of the
web page that you
are using as a link
for us to play within.
And then, of course, must be
delivered as a browser game,
running on Chrome.
And also, only in those engines
that w e used in the tutorial.
Deliverables-- so actually,
this is Monday the 29th.
Wednesday is the 1st.
On Wednesday the 1st, we have
a guest lecture coming in.
Swery65 is coming in to talk
to us about his new game.
His lecture is probably
going to last about an hour.
That means you're going to have
two hours in class on Wednesday
to work in teams and create
a low fidelity prototype.
It is not something you're
required to turn in.
We are asking you to have
a playable game on Monday,
the 6th.
Whether that's digital or paper
is up to you, but we highly,
highly, highly recommend making
a quick, low fidelity prototype
on Wednesday in the two
hours you have, and then
based on that prototype
create the product backlog.
It's the best way that I've
found to make product backlogs.
You might find a different way.
That's OK, as long
as you make one.
But on Monday, on the
6th, turn in the Stellar,
your high level design doc, and
what your product backlog is.
So what are all
the features that
have been estimated, that have
been put in priority order?
In class, you're going
to give a really quick--
AUDIENCE: Next slide.
PROFESSOR: What's up?
AUDIENCE: You're talking
about stuff on the next one.
PROFESSOR: Oh, wow.
I'm talking about
stuff on the next one.
Thank you.
That's weird.
In class, two minute
presentations.
Basically, just the core
of your game design idea.
Let us know what you're making.
And then we'll be able
to test your prototypes.
I think-- let me look ahead.
Yeah, so testing prototype
is not required on the 6th.
But if you do it, please
we'll test them then.
We will also test
on-- and this is
where we actually
do want you to have
a playable, digital version.
Basically, let us know that you
have a playable game by October
8.
And turn in via Stellar
your sprint task list--
basically all the tasks
with time estimates
that are going to happen
between Wednesday, October
8 and Monday, October 15.
And the project due is
the same kind of stuff
that we did for this
project-- your game prototype
builds, your post mortems,
your design change
log, updated design document
if you have an updated design
document.
And again, two focus
test reports this time.
One can be created in class
on either the 6th or the 8th.
The other one should be
created outside of class
with external testers.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that Monday the
13th or Wednesday the 15th?
PROFESSOR: Oh, my lord.
Did I really make that mistake?
Can somebody check
on Stellar for me?
So it should be Monday
the 13th, right?
AUDIENCE: No, we
think it's Wednesday.
PROFESSOR: Wednesday
the 15th is when we're
having people turn stuff in?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: All right, holiday.
Right?
Is there a holiday that week?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Stellar is the right place,
and I will update these slides
before I post them to Stellar.
AUDIENCE: Let me check
on the big schedule.
It's Columbus Day.
So Monday, there is no class.
PROFESSOR: So Monday, no class.
So Wednesday, the 15th.
So you got a little
bit of extra time.
But it's a holiday, so maybe
you don't have extra time.
PHILLIP: But if you
get it done by Monday,
then you can let your code
soak a little bit [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
So we are going to
do brainstorming,
and we're going to brainstorm
in groups that you are not
currently working with, so
you can meet new people.
You're going to get a card.
It's going to have a number
on it-- one, two, three, five,
eight, or 13.
I'll hand out the
cards really quickly.
Go to one of these stations,
erase whatever's on the board
if you need to
erase on the board.
If you're in five,
eight, or 13, you're
going to have these easel pads.
We are going to give you two
timed quick brainstorming
sessions.
Five minutes, small break,
another five minutes.
When we break, change
whoever's writing things down
so everybody has
a chance to speak.
After this, each
brainstorm group
is going to be allowed to
make two pitches to the larger
class.
What we're going
to ask you to do
is write a title for the
game on a large Post-It,
and we'll hand these out.
One of these, yeah.
We'll hand these out
when we get there.
In your elevator pitch,
make sure to address
the core mechanic of the
game and how it's applied
to the design constraints.
Games from project one that were
not selected for project two
can be pitched if your
brainstorming group says
that was actually
a pretty cool idea.
Let's pitch that too.
But it must be altered
for design constraints.
And I'll give you a break
after that second brainstorming
session to come up with these
pitches-- about 10 minutes,
I think.
Any questions about this?
Psyched?
Pumped?
All right, I'm going
to hand these out.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PROFESSOR: Team one,
pitch one, come on down.
And just like before,
you've got about a minute.
Describe-- oops, wrong ones.
Give us the name of the
pitch, the core mechanic,
and how this pitch approaches
the design constraint.
Pitch, go.
PRESENTER 16: So our first
pitch is called Dragon's Lair.
It bears no relation to the
previous Dragon's Lair idea.
The idea we came up with is
that as a dragon, when you're
acquiring gold, the
more gold you have,
the more heroes want to
come in and mess you up
to try and steal your stuff.
So we thought that there's
a fun trade-off there
between acquiring
more gold and becoming
a more powerful dragon,
but at the same time
having more and
more heroes wanting
to come in and attack you.
We also thought that
just in that, in itself,
you don't quite get the idea
of meaningful decisions,
because everybody's
just going to want
to be a more powerful dragon and
prove themselves as, oh, I can
handle more and more knights.
So we thought it'd be
interesting to have
this idea of not just
being an enemy to everyone.
You can actually ally with some
of the villages in the game
so you'll be making less
money, but then you'd
have more people on your
side to help you defend.
So the trade-off here is
between being nice to people
in order to get more
defense or slaughtering them
or just steal their money.
PROFESSOR: Nice pitch.
Number two.
PRESENTER 17: All right,
so our second game
is called caffeine worker.
And it's based on the idea
that caffeine will pretty much
simulate your [INAUDIBLE]
where you can actually
get more work done under
less amount of sleep.
But it also tends to
have side effects.
So our game pretty much revolves
around you are a worker,
and you want to get
these tasks done.
And you want to get these done
as efficiently as possible.
So we're going to have
something like a 24 hour clock.
We're going to
have night and day.
We're going to have a lot
of different sort of actions
that you can sort of, like,
decide on executing, such
as you can figure out how
many hours you want to sleep,
how much caffeine
you want to take,
and also you can also figure out
your eating schedule as well.
So we don't really have
the nitty-gritty details,
but we imagine that
this game will involve
a lot of scheduling, a lot
of sort of-- I don't know,
the trade-offs between sleeping
and eating and drinking coffee.
But in the end, I
think what we want
to do is that we want
to make this game
sort of like a platformer,
where you are actual in control
of the character
and for [INAUDIBLE]
your tasks, something you need
to go from point A to point B.
But these different sort of
attributes, how much caffeine
you have over time,
how much sleep you
have, whether you're eating
enough, whether you're happy
or not-- those sort of
effect your motor skills
as well as some
other implementations
that we have yet to figure out.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Thank you.
Thank you group one.
Group two.
Pitch one, category A. Remember,
it's one-minute pitches.
PRESENTER 18: All right,
so here's the idea.
You are an administrator at MIT.
And your goal is the management
of MIT and promote MIT's ideals
and maximize their
endowment and all that.
And your goal is to carefully
trade-off the short-term
versus long-term policy.
For example, you've
got this plot of land.
You could lease it to Pfizer
for 60 years and get 2 billion
straight to the endowment.
But then you can't
expand it till later.
And do you want to appease
the students to get more
in tuition?
But maybe you need that
money, so you raise tuition,
but you also get rid of
your unpopular flag policy
at the same time.
So you can play as many
different administrators.
You can play as,
like, Dean Colombo.
You can play as Kevin
Kraft from the Office
of Student Citizenship.
You can play as the
shady MIT corporation
with this weird board
of self-voting members
that no one really understands.
That's our pitch one.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: What's
the name of that one?
PRESENTER 18: MIT
Simulator 2015.
PRESENTER 19: Our second
idea is build a car.
And we thought that
you could start out
with a limited amount
of money, and we
will send the car you
build after a turn
through a simulator.
And so you don't exactly know
which maze it's going to get.
So depending on
the result of that,
you have trade-offs of
how to spend your money,
what parts to buy,
and build a car.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Group three.
PRESENTER 20: Hi, everyone.
I'm going to tell you about
Fight or Flight, which
is from our first project.
And if anyone played
the paper prototype,
it's going to be
completely different.
So the idea is that you're
playing this platformer, which
is a map that has a bunch
of separate little rooms.
So any given little room might
have four or five platforms.
It's not really big.
And so this whole
big map has a bunch
of these little
rooms, all connected
by different passageways.
And you can get from different
places to different places.
And all of these rooms
are potentially exploding.
So this is some
sort of spaceship,
and there's a meltdown.
Or, I don't know, this
is, like, the tavern.
And near a volcano,
things are filling
with lava, or something.
However you want to skin it.
So each of the
rooms will give you
some sort of warning
about whether or not
it's about to explode.
And then some time after the
warning starts, it explodes.
And then if you're in
there, you're in trouble.
So the trade-offs
in this game are
that-- so the overall goal is
to get somewhere, is to get out,
is to get from one side
of the map to the other.
And in between, there's a
whole bunch of other people
who want to fight you,
just for the heck of it.
So they want to fight you,
you want to fight them.
But the more you fight,
the more tired you get.
And the more tired you
get, the slower you move.
And the more slowly
you move, the harder
it is to escape a room
once it starts exploding.
So you can choose to
fight, and you're probably
going to kill them, you
could kill the enemies
because they're AI written
by people in this class.
Versus, like, the player who
can actually just implement
strategies and things.
But if you do go and have fun
and try to kick everyone's ass
and you succeed at
that, well, then you're
panting in the middle of a
room that's about to explode.
So fight or flight everyone.
PRESENTER 21: The second
one is Jigsaw World,
another platformer where you are
inside a jigsaw puzzle, where
every time you get to the
end of a block section
square thing-- they're oddly
shaped because it's a jigsaw
puzzle-- you get a choice
of a new set of tiles
to put on the end of the
one you've already gotten.
Sometimes you have to
go back and pick one up
off the beginning of your
puzzle and put it at the end.
And various power-ups make
certain ones incompatible,
like being able to fly.
That means you can't swim.
Being able to swim
means you can't jump--
all those kinds of things.
You're kind of creating
your own world that you then
have to navigate differently.
Oh, yeah.
And deconstruct it.
You never get to see
the whole thing at once
because it's falling apart as
you're taking it and moving it
somewhere.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Group five.
PRESENTER 22: So
our first idea is
a game called The Gun
Wars, in which you're
managing a defense company.
And you're trading
off who you're
going to sell your
product to amidst
a bunch of different clients.
So you could have
somebody go up to you,
you get some information
on who they are, say, hey,
this is James, seems
like an OK guy,
and he wants to buy,
like, 10,000 missiles,
air-to-surface
missiles or something.
You have to surmise
him, figure out
if that's somebody
you want to sell to,
figure out at what
price you want to sell.
And then there may be some
consequences for that.
Maybe you sell to
Jimmy, and then he
launches an attack on some
country you like or don't like.
But more importantly,
maybe he does
something your other
clients like or don't like.
And so you lose other business.
Or you get new business from
people that are Jimmy's friends
and realize they can
buy weapons from you.
So it's sort of a social
responsibility game.
You're a defense contractor.
You're managing some
pool of money, trying
to make money off of contracts.
And the trade-offs
come with who you're
deciding to buy and sell from.
PRESENTER 23: Our second idea
for the game is Bullet Craft.
Bullet Craft is a fast-paced,
top-down shooter game
that follows the simple
formula, the classic formula,
that the player controls
the ship, moves around,
[INAUDIBLE] that's
coming at him,
and shoots the
enemies that spawns
from the top of the screen.
Well, you might ask,
where does trade-offs come
into play for Bullet Craft?
So there are
actually various ways
we can augment the
game play so that we
will incorporate trade-offs.
For example, on
the micro level, we
can have ammo limits
or overheating guns.
And we can have a fuel limit
which if the player moves,
he consumes fuel which
pollutes the environment,
and the enemies become stronger
because of that pollution.
At the macro level,
we could also
have the player choosing
different types of weapons,
spending their money on
different types of ships
and even a crew.
What I like about
Bullet Craft is
it is very easy to implement,
and it's guaranteed to be fun,
so that if we make
Bullet Craft, we
are sure that we will be able
to make a successful game.
PROFESSOR: Group eight.
PRESENTER 24: So the first
idea we had is Daydream Inc.
So in this game, you're like
a regular office worker.
And you have to try
and not get fired.
But the goal of the game is
to succeed in your daydreams.
So there's basically two
mini-games within the game.
There's surviving
the office life,
and then there's
also your daydreams
where you're fighting
your boss or something.
And it's interesting
because you use tools
from the office to build
weapons for your daydreams.
So you might get a
stapler and a rubber band
and make a staple gun or
something for your daydreams.
So you have to spend both time
and research from the office
life in the daydreams
without getting fired,
so you can eventually
win the game.
Also, if you become
CEO in the office life,
so if you do really well
there too, you lose.
PRESENTER 25: So our
second idea was Score High.
So basically, you're
an MIT student.
And you have a list of
maybe three classes.
And you have some stats-- like,
your food, sleep, happiness,
health.
And the thing is, each of your
classes has PSETs and tests.
And you have to get
to the tests on time,
and you also have to turn
in your PSETs on time.
And so how do you do that?
So you run around
the maze, and you
have to get to the right
building at the right time.
But you also, when
you're there, actually
have to take the tests.
And depending on-- you
pick up different items.
And say you drink 10 cups of
coffee, you're really jittery.
Instead of seeing all of the
options for the multiple choice
question, suddenly
you can't look at it,
and you only see one question.
And somehow you miss
the back of the page.
So you fail the test, right?
So the whole game is
about choosing-- you know,
when am I going to drink coffee?
Or maybe I'll buy
my friend coffee,
and he'll give me
the PSET answers
so I don't have to spend
five minutes doing the PSET.
And managing those
trade-offs while also
running around this
maze and getting
everything done on time.
And if you fail any of
your classes, you lose.
PROFESSOR: Group
13, come on down.
PRESENTER 26: Our first
idea is Ghost Face.
The title's a working title.
The idea is you're in a
maze, actually a maze.
And you have very
limited visibility.
You can only see
a certain radius
that is much smaller than
the actual size of the maze.
And there's ghosts
coming at you.
And basically the idea is to get
to the other side of the maze,
solving the maze, but you
only have limited disability.
So you have to explore the maze
and remember which path was
a good decision and
which path wasn't.
So you have to trace back a lot.
You can also add in more things.
Like, you may have
a certain number
of beacons, light
beacons, that you
can place in different areas,
but a limited number of them.
So you want to be-- you want
to make a decision as to what
would be a strategically
good place to place a beacon
and reveal an important and
critical part of the maze
so that you can see
more of the maze.
So that's our first idea.
PRESENTER 27: So our second
idea revolves around DNA.
We haven't found a
good title for it.
But the idea is, let's
say there's an organism.
And you have a certain
set of diseases
that you want to
try to get rid of.
And your goal is to somehow go
around finding other organisms
that have their set of traits.
What's the diseases
that you don't have,
some other diseases
that you have.
And play a game of
chance-- so whether it's
worth it to spend your
time and energy eating
or mating with
the other organism
and seeing if those genes come
across to your [INAUDIBLE].
And the trade-off
is-- the trade-off is,
do you want to mate with
this organism or not?
We're still working on
the details of this,
but the idea is this gene
competition [INAUDIBLE].
PRESENTER 28: And
random mutation.
PRESENTER 27: Yeah, random
mutations [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Thank you.
All right.
We're actually really
good on time today,
so you'll actually have some
time to work in your teams
after we get you all sorted out.
So we heard about Dragon's Lair,
Caffeine Worker, MIT Simulator,
Build a Car, Fight or Flight,
Jigsaw World, The Gun Wars,
Bullet Craft, Daydream Inc.,
Score High, Ghost Maze,
and DNA.
12 ideas-- actually,
a few of them
could probably combine
pretty well together.
So we're not really
throwing the ideas away.
We're really just trying to
get together into groups of six
around a base idea
we can start with.
So if you've got a game
that you're really, really
excited about working
on, come right down
and put your name on it.
And make sure your Post-It
has your name and the game
engine you used in the
tutorial assignments.
Let's see what we got.
All right, raise your
hand if you still have
your name tag, your Post-It.
One, two, three, four.
All right.
We have Caffeine Worker
only has one person on.
[? Zigamantias ?], you
have your name tag back.
Nope, sit down.
Just sit down.
Jigsaw World.
Sorry, Kathleen.
All right.
We've got one, two,
three, four, five, six.
DNA is done.
So DNA is Derek, Eduardo, Ava,
Harry, Trisha, and Lauren.
One, two, three for Ghost Maze.
Three for Score High.
Two for Daydream.
None for Gun Wars.
Two for Bullet Craft.
Three for Fight or Flight.
One, two, three,
four for Build a Car.
Two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, cool.
MIT Simulator.
Don't get me in trouble.
Norman, Jordan, James,
Peter, [? Szeun, ?] and Sam.
Bullet Craft and
Daydream-- first off,
does anybody who has
their name tag on them,
are they all excited about
either of these two games?
AUDIENCE: I am.
PROFESSOR: You are?
Is your name-- do you have
your name tag in your hand?
OK, raise your hand if you have
your name tag in your hand.
All right, come down here
and put your name on a game.
I'm going to get them all.
I think we have enough
to get every game to six.
10, nine, eight,
seven, six-- hey, five.
Cool.
Thank you.
All right, Fight or
Flight, Bullet Craft,
Daydream I think
are all either going
to go away or combine somehow.
Score High, one,
two, three, four.
One, two, three, four,
five on Ghost Maze.
Just needs one more person.
Five on Build a Car.
Four on Dragon's Lair.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
OK.
Daydream is gone,
Bullet Craft is gone,
Fight or Flight is gone.
Move yourself to another team.
All right, Ghost Maze
has six and is done.
Score High has five, six.
Done.
AUDIENCE: Everything
is full, isn't it?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So put yourself on one,
two, three, four, five, six.
Put yourself on any of them.
Five, four, three,
two-- thank you.
So here are our final teams.
We're going to do
one last shuffle.
If anyone is like, I don't
want to really be on that one,
they can move to another.
For Dragon's Lair, we have Roy,
[? Mikael, ?] Liz, Zigamantis,
Devon, Caleb, and Kathleen.
You have a good mix
of Unity and Flixel,
so I imagine you might
use Unity or Flixel.
Build a Car, we have Rodrigo,
Anderson, Matt, [? Taj ?],
Jeremy, and [INAUDIBLE].
We have Unity, Unity, Unity--
three Unity, three Phaser.
I wonder what
you're going to use.
Score High, six.
Miriam, [? Sen ?], Megan,
Kevin, Sabrina, and [? Zinue ?].
And we have Haxe, Haxe, Flixel.
Oh, wow, lots of Flixel.
And two Unity.
So maybe one of those.
Ghost Maze, [? Jutoshka ?],
[? Salaam ?], Daniel, Kevin,
Justin, and Rachel.
And Unity, Unity, HaxeFlixel.
Ooh, it's going to
be kind of tough.
We've got three Phaser, two
Unity, and one HaxeFlixel,
so that's going to be a
hard decision to make.
DNA, we've got seven-- Jenny,
Lauren, Ava, Tricia, Harry,
Eduardo, Derek.
HaxeFlixel, HaxeFlixel,
HaxeFlixel, Flixel, and one
Unity.
So probably one of the Flixels.
[GROANING]
You decide.
MIT Simulator has Unity, Unity,
Unity, Unity, Unity, Unity,
Unity.
Four Unitys and two
Phasers, so probably Unity.
And that is Norman,
Jordan, James, Peter,
Sam, and [? Szeun. ?] We have
how many students are not
in class today?
Five or six students
not in class today.
They are going to
have to-- what's up?
AUDIENCE: Make them a team.
AUDIENCE: Game to learn
how not to be late.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
PHILLIP: [INAUDIBLE]
simultaneously on Wednesday,
that might be possible.
But if a few of them don't
come back on Wednesday,
that may not work.
PROFESSOR: So teams will
be finalized on Wednesday.
These are the teams as
they stand right now.
You have 40 minutes
to meet as a team
to figure out if you
all match schedules,
to talk about the
idea you just pitched,
and make a really
quick lo-fi prototype,
or write down that page
that you just said out loud
on the spur of the moment.
Figure out what is that
game that you're making.
Work on that vision statement.
And feel free to
grab your things
and put your names
on it if you like.